bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 7 décembre
nous sommes encore loin de l'objectif
des 5000 cas par jour jérôme cénomans
alerte la saison hivernale sera très
difficile
le directeur général de la santé s'est
exprimé tout à l'heure insistant sur le
risque élevé de repos et bill et mick
alors que les fêtes de noël approchent
des propos pessimistes avant une
nouvelle prise de parole de jean castex
ce joli avec des annonces à attendre le
répertoire s'étoffe celui des fichiers
utilisés par la police nationale et la
gendarmerie à des fins de maintien de
l'ordre public
depuis vendredi dernier la publication
de trois décrets du ministère de
l'intérieur permettent d' ainsi
d'augmenter les capacités de fichage des
individus allant des données de santé
aux pratiques sportives en passant par
les activités sur les réseaux sociaux
la cnil elle émet des réserves
[Musique]
emmanuel macron dit avoir évoqué en
toute franchise la question des droits
de l'homme avec son homologue égyptien
en visite d'état de deux jours en france
mais il ne conditionne pas la
coopération entre paris et le caire a
cédé accord selon ses propres mots
interrogé sur la publication des
caricatures de mahomet en france le
président égyptien affirmé que les
valeurs religieuses devait avoir la
suprématie sur les valeurs humaines la
valeur de l'homme est supérieur à tout
lui a répondu emmanuel macron c'est la
conclusion d'une enquête importante
celle menée par l'organisation non
gouvernementale israélienne breaking the
silence les projets en cours ou
planifiés de construction routière en
cisjordanie représente le plus important
développement d'infrastructures au
profit des colonies israéliennes et ce
depuis les années 1990
[Musique]
le directeur général de la santé jérôme
salomon a donc tenu un point presse tout
à l'heure sur l'évolution de la crise
sanitaire alors que se profile un
éventuel déconfinement le 15 décembre
prochain
pour plus de précisions nous retrouvons
tout de suite notre reporter à nadège ad
razak en direct du ministère de la santé
bonsoir nadège une prise de parole donc
du directeur général qui n'augure rien
de bon
absolument stéphanie le déconfinement au
15 décembre n'aura peut-être pas lieu
comme annoncé par emmanuel macron le 24
novembre dernier
ce jour là le chef de l'état avait
annoncé un objectif à atteindre de 5
mille nouveaux cas de contamination par
jour au minimum pour diminuer les
restrictions sanitaires et aujourd'hui
on en est au double à une semaine
maintenant de l'échéance le directeur
général de l' agence de santé publique
s'est montré inquiet aujourd'hui lors de
sa conférence de presse il a prévenu
qu'il faudra attendre les prochains
jours pour prendre d'éventuelles mesures
supplémentaires afin de lutter contre la
propagation du virus jérôme salomon a
aussi déclaré que si le taux de
contamination était toujours aussi élevé
il n'est pas dû au comportement des
français un éventuel relâchement de leur
part mais aux conditions météorologiques
au froid à l'hiver tout simplement une
saison qui est propice à la
prolifération des virus
interrogé sur les fêtes de fin d'année
jérôme salomon a appelé les français au
bon sens il les a encouragés à continuer
à respecter les gestes sanitaires alors
un conseil de défense est prévue ce
mercredi on sait déjà que jean castex
prendra la parole le lendemain pour
peut-être annoncé et des nouvelles
difficiles avec un éventuel report du
déconfinement merci nadège de razac en
direct du ministère de la santé et
jérôme seulement predy predy donc un
hiver très difficile le directeur de la
santé qui donne le ton et appelle à la
prudence avant
un nouveau point presse de jean castex
attendu ce jeudi pour revenir sur cette
prise de parole place à notre décryptage
avec nos invités prix pour en parler
nous sommes avec pierre-jean terne amian
radiologue président des médecins
libéraux d'auvergne rhône alpes ainsi
que ludovic toro médecin porte parole du
collectif de soignant ses 19 bonsoir à
tous les deux merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france vous avez donc
suivi ce point presse de jérôme salomon
aujourd'hui pas très positif a
aujourd'hui le directeur de la santé
chaque jour plus de dix mille personnes
sont testés positifs contre 5000 par
semaine au coeur de l'été ludovic toro
comment on peut s'expliquer ce très
mauvais bilan
mais il faut qu'on arrête de donner des
chiffres des prévisions et et courir
après les choses qu'on tient pas à ce
que ça c'est le message très négatif
alors on n'est pas de problème dormez
tranquilles on a tout mis en place on
aura famille contaminée et aujourd'hui
on dit que c'est pas possible on
n'arrête pas de faire des annonces des
contrats non si les îles étant
d'anticiper
on connaît ce virus aujourd'hui on est
on est à 15 % à peu près d' immunité
collective 15% on était à 8 % au 1er ou
finement et on doit atteindre 70%
pourquoi ça s'arrêterait aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui j'ai entendu que vous
disiez qu'on accélère si je peux me
permettre ludovic vous avez raison mais
on sait très bien qu'on hiver on est
tous les uns et chez les autres et rien
est ouvert c'est comme toutes les
épidémies
on n'est pas en été où le faire on n'a
pas découvert qu'en décembre ont fermé
les fenêtres et on restait dans les
maisons je veux dire tout ça c'est à ce
prix mois il pas besoin de faire des
grands discours c'est toujours comme ça
où ses quais virus parce que quand vous
fermez les fenêtres fermées les portes
devraient à l'intérieur vous êtes plus
contaminés ne n'incriminons pas la
météorologie et tout ce qui va avec
c'était prévisible on est très loin
l'immunité collective
donc je vois pas sur quoi en plus qui
sent de plus en plus de liberté on
pouvait imaginer que ça allait descendre
tout seul pourquoi faire de son annonce
qu'on n'est pas sûr faut arrêter de
faire de l'amateurisme petites annonces
parce que vous
crédibiliser la parole vous d'être
immunisé la communication qui doit être
et pas par de la politique mais par de
l'ami de file jean pierre pierre jean
pardon ternes amiens au lieu de victor
ono dit voilà faut arrêter de faire des
annonces mais en fait il n'y a pas eu
que des annonces je précise il ya eu
quand même des mesures assez sévère on
est encore en train de faire des
attestations quand on sort de chez nous
on n'est pas supposé se réunir le soir
il ya un confinement qui est en cours
comment vous vous expliquer je réitère
quand même ma question ces mauvais
chiffres qui sont inquiétants
alors on va dire c'est pas forcément des
mauvais chiffres
c'est une décélération le problème c'est
que depuis à peu près une semaine on est
en plateau il en est en plateau parce
que on a une sorte de plancher et sur
lequel on n'arrive pas à descendre qui à
peu près dix mille trois cent on a
toujours des régions qui sont largement
au dessus on va dire de sang ça
s'explique probablement par la
réouverture des commerces
c'est indéniable et on a un exemple
caricatural de ce qui nous attend si
vous voulez pour noël et le jour de l'an
ciel tandis qu'ils me on a un petit peu
perdues pierre-jean terme agnant je vois
là on vous a récupéré je vais vous
laisser finir votre propos bon alors ça
ne fonctionne pas on va retrouver jean
pierre pierre jeantet remaniant le cap
un des 5 me la contamination par jour du
coc vite fixés par emmanuel macron pour
lever le confinement au 15 décembre
s'avèrent
difficile à atteindre ludovic toro ça va
vous énervez parce que voilà il redonne
1 ce fameux cap
ce chiffre mais n'empêche qu'ils ont
fondé leur stratégie là dessus c'est un
nouveau dilemme maintenant pour le
gouvernement
ben c'est pas un dilemme c'est un échec
merci on fonde nos stratégies sont des
choses qui arrivent pas forcément pourra
pas le mettre en place
c'est à dire je vis tout le monde espère
qu'il y aura une décroissance tout le
monde mais on n'est pas un nombre de
contaminés assez importants sur double
vaccination n'arrivera pas tendre tout
de suite je suis pas sûr que tout le
monde se fassent vacciner
de par ses erreurs de communication
qu'on arrête de faire de faire des plans
comme ça bastions on se trompe pas
chaque fois
donc maintenant je voulais dire on est
allé à tout casser 15% de contamination
à toute la population
le virus va continuer d'accord il va
encore toucher des personnes ça c'est
évident mais voilà donc maintenant ce
qu'il faut continuer le plus joli mois
on est toujours comme on dire on
n'anticipe pas c'est un virus
ok personne ne connaisse à 27 vous avez
annoncé que sûrement avec la chaleur
avec le froid avec le vent il a disparu
il ya rien qui disparaît il est toujours
là il résiste à tous et il veut
contaminer le maxi dans des populations
ça c'est sûr donc voilà on va voir
maintenant en effet aujourd'hui ont des
consignes et ben les chiffres montrent
pas seulement à cause des profils
manquez pas ces vieux c'est parce que le
virus continue à progresser et c'est
vrai que l'hiver est un et comme on
dirait est un moment où il ya plus de
contaminations quelles que soient les
russes
jérôme salomon qui a précisé que les
français se sont auto bien comportée que
les chiffres étaient entre guillemets
moins pire que chez nos voisins
européens ou aux qu'ailleurs vous êtes
d'accord avec ce diagnostic
mais alors au début je vous rappelle
quand même le discours était différent
c'est la faute des citoyens qui respecte
est rien maintenant on respecte bien et
maintenant on va se comparer aux pays
européens
peut-être qu'il aurait fallu se comparer
au début c'est un peu facile de se
comparer pour faire un pas sur les
autres ne se compare pas quand ça va
bien
donc voilà l'europe aujourd'hui chaque
pays a fait ce qu'il voulait on a bien
vu
le seul moment les européens se sont
réunis c'est pour faire une commande
financière sur les vagues ça c'est tout
il n'y a aucune politique européenne sur
le coït 19 et nous le voyons bien dans
les différentes annonces qui sont faites
sur des vers une fermeture et ouverture
donc l'europe a été absente et je vous
rappelle
l'échec total de l'étude discovery qui
avait été mis en place les cas pas
abouti donc arrêtons de nous comparer
aux autres pays balayons un peu devant
notre porte ça serait mieux on a encore
des choses à faire parce qu' on est loin
très loin de la fin de cette pandémie
donc attention aux effets d'annoncé
pourquoi pouvoir décevoir nos citoyens
ludovic toro je vous propose un avant de
retrouver pierre jean hermann un
problème de liaison internet d'écouté
jérôme salomon avec la venue des fêtes
de noël qui évidemment inquiète
à l'instar de ce qui s'est passé avec
fanzhi mine aux états unis écouter les
fêtes de fin d'année font craindre que
des contaminations importante
intrafamiliales et lieu comme cela a été
observé lors des fêtes de thanksgiving
au canada puis aux états unis et donc je
passe un message très clair de
prévention de prudence
un appel au bon sens et à la protection
renforcée
deux des personnes les plus fragiles de
nos proches de nos aînés en chérasse
jérôme saignements qui fait appel au bon
sens des français c'est la bonne
stratégie il ne faut pas prévoir plus de
restrictions légales en tout cas pour
ces fêtes selon vous mais dans les
français des citoyens se rendent bien
compte que c'est que tous les jours il
ya des personnes qui meurent de squid
ils vont tout faire pour protéger leurs
charmes y est surtout les plus fragiles
et les personnes âgées
donc ce que salomon rappelle murray puis
tout le monde connaît tous les français
connaissent d'accord donc maintenant
voilà il faut arrêter d'infantiliser
infantiliser comment les citoyens ils
ont vu ces morts on a encore trois cents
morts par jour ça continue c'est pas
fini donc personne ne veut mourir à
suite à ces fêtes de fin d'année et je
pense que la plupart des gens un front
attention à pas contaminer surtout les
personnes les plus fragiles pierre
jeantet remaniant on vous retrouve avec
bonheur
on disait donc un ce cap des 5000
contamination par jour fixé par emmanuel
macron pour changer sa stratégie alléger
ces restrictions et bien ça va être
compliqué de l'atteindre
vous en tant que médecin vous espérez
quoi justement de cette deuxième phase 1
qui était prévue au 15 décembre on parle
également des fêtes de fin d'année qui
vont forcément être un moment tendu dans
cette crise sanitaire
pourtant ce que le gouvernorat pas le
choix il faudra qu'ils remontent lundi
on commence à susurrer que ça va être
7000 8000 le souci je réitère ses tantes
giving qui est un exemple l'exemple
américain où on est à peu près sûr qu'on
va dire à la mi janvier on à la
troisième vague
si effectivement on a un relâchement on
a un relâchement depuis à peu près une
dizaine de jours avec ouverture des
commerces donc automatiquement les
chiffres aux montants nets en plateau on
n'a aucune idée de l'évolution du
plateau et dans tous les cas on
n'atteindra pas les 5000 ça c'est sûr en
tout cas le l'espoir semble être le
vaccin le seul espoir en tout cas
puisque vous nous dit tous les deux que
cette pandémie va continuer à progresser
je vous propose d'écouter sur ce point
jérôme salomon la vaccination représente
un espoir majeur mais elle ne produira
ses effets que dans de nombreux mois car
une proportion importante de la
population doit être immunisé il faudra
du temps pour arriver à un contrôle de
l'épidémie
alors que les conditions de propagation
du virus persiste
l'histoire de l'humanité et des maladies
infectieuses nous a démontré que l'
isolement des personnes contagieuses la
vaccination et le respect de l'ensemble
des mesures d'hygiène restent les
interventions qui ont sauvé le plus de
vies dans le passé et qu'elle risque de
le rester encore pour longtemps
bon ludovic toro alors c'est pas très
encourageant non plus ça va prendre du
temps bon rappelle quand même que la
russie a commencé à vacciner là
aujourd'hui
le royaume uni c'est pour demain avec la
reine d'angleterre en tête
d'ailleurs ça va mettre un peu plus de
temps pour nous les français
je rappelle les chiffres on allait les
sondages donnent 70 % des allemands qui
vont se faire vacciner 80 % des anglais
et 40% des français
ça va être nous et le gouvernement les a
compris les médecins généralistes de
dire oui ou non les idées les personnes
à faire un choix
par rapport à cela cette façon nous le
vaccin on va pas d'avoir tout de suite
c'est même bac 5 avec qui va être fait
demain en angleterre et qui sera fait
chez nous dans un mois puisque rider
c'est celui qui va être tenu bon et qui
sera pas fait chez le généraliste dur en
fait au devoir de garder les vaccins du
92 sont pas possibles
le prochain modern sera on pourra le
garder mais le travail qu'on a à faire
aujourd'hui on convaincre les gens de se
faire vacciner
je voulais dire qu aujourd hui dans ma
consultation il n'y a pas une personne
qui m'a dit qu'elle est servie si vous
entendez ce que je vous dis voilà on en
est aujourd'hui et comme je vous le
rappelle il ya deux solutions soit on
attend les 70% de l'immunité collective
et on en aura donc dans trois ans on
voit près du corps ça progresse
soit on fait quelque chose avant pour
que cela s'arrête et aujourd'hui vous
intéressant parce que vous dites voilà
dans vos cabinets il n'y a pas beaucoup
de gens qui ont envie de se faire
vacciner vous leur répondez quoi ces
personnes moi j'en dis une chose déjà
première chose qu'est ce qu'on va faire
si on fait rien c'est que c'est que
c'est pas notre solution c'est
d'attendre de fermer d'ouvrir de
recommencer aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
d'autre possibilité que que celle là
donc il faut voir qu'on discute moi je
pense que les gens est plus fragile
voilà il ya que c'est quand même une
maladie mortelle qui touche une
catégorie de population qui ne connaît
très bien donc il n'ya pas dira pas
alors maintenant certain d'être attendre
un vaccin qui est fait chez nous qui est
fait par pasteur ça il ya une discussion
qui savent avoir par rapport à ça parce
que les deux premiers se base sur la rn
message est une c'est différent c'est
une des premières fois qu'on utilise ce
type de vaccin dans notre pays voilà
résumée à un moment sur l'art tous
ensemble mais le problème si on n'avait
qu'à 40%
je vous rappelle la conférence de presse
du premier ministre et quelques jours où
ils ont nommé quelqu'un donc pour gérer
les vaccins monsieur fisher le
professeur fisher qui dans son discours
disait le contraire de
le premier ministre vous êtes on n'est
pas sûr qu'on doit faire attention
excusez moi ce genre de discours mais ça
ne fait qu'accroître les gens qui sont
sceptiques par rapport à une vaccination
fait dire à un moment il va falloir que
tout le monde dit la même chose vous par
la même chose aujourd'hui c'est clair on
ne fait rien on part sur trois ans on
fait quelque chose on a qu'une chose
c'est le vaccin faut qu'on en discute
façon il arrivera pas chez nous avant un
mois un mois et demi donc d'ici là on
verra si on attend pasteur si on
franchit shirt voilà où on en est
aujourd'hui le retour d'expérience en
tout cas de nos amis britanniques
genre on va laisser pardonnez-moi
ludovic toro va passer parce qu'on
arrive à la fin de notre débat le mot de
la fin pour pierre jeantet remaniant sur
ses vaccins ça vous inquiète que vient
de nous dire est ce qu on sait
évidemment ludovic toro 60% environ 1
des français qui ne compte pas se faire
vacciner le gouvernement un travail de
pédagogie sur ce dossier mais mon
confrère a raison mais un travail de
pédagogie aussi à faire envers les
médecins libéraux pour une raison très
simple
l'ensemble des contrats qu'on appuie
examiné au niveau du rps ces lignes on
va dire le blanc seing pour ne pas avoir
de poursuites de la part des
laboratoires qui fabriquent le vaccin
impunité totale
deuxième point le gouvernement ne rend
pas la vaccination obligatoire donc pas
moins responsable
qu'est ce qui va être responsable on
nous l'a dit lors de la conférence de
presse de présentation du mines du
premier ministre le médecin en médecin
libéral pas de soucis yalom neame alors
c'est long c'est l'office national
d'indemnisation des accidents médicaux
donc on n'a pas de documentation sur ses
vaccins on a uniquement des communiqués
de presse
on a des vaccins qui sont à arn sur
lequel on n'a aucune maîtrise le seul
qui a été testée c'est beau là on est
obligé de l'arrêter à cause d'effets
secondaires et on va aller effectivement
alors que je suis très pro vaccin soul
et je défends un carnet de vaccination
électronique et une matinée sur une
grande échelle
parce qu'effectivement la variole
éradiquée quasiment faire 3 10% de la
population on va dire amérindienne
autrefois mais je suis dans une
situation où en tant que patron des
médecins libéraux de ma région je sais
je ne savons pas dire actuellement quels
sont les types de vaccins le con qu'on
aura avec les effets secondaires nous
n'avons pas de registre vaccinale
la cnam nous promet peut-être un système
informatique vague il n'est même pas
écrit la première réunion de travail
c'est le 11 novembre
est ce que vous pensez sincèrement que
madame la caisse est en capacité de
développer un logiciel qui marchent en
deux mois mais c'est à mourir de rire
le problème c'est que c'est grave et en
plus le médecin
au final le professionnel de santé qui
va faire l'injection parce qu'il aura
réussi à convaincre son patient et qu'il
est lui-même convaincu de l'intérêt de
la vaccination
il ira plutôt sur un vaccin était nu et
on va dire genre sanofi ça c'est clair
plutôt que les rênes de tenir à moins 80
des cas on peut pas le distribuer mais
c'est lui qui est responsable donc moi
je demande qu'on ait le statut de
collaborateur on va dire du service
public quand on fera une ce type
d'injection
sinon c'est celle c'est nous envoyer à
l'abattoir on a envoyé à l'abattoir lors
de la première séquence avec l'absence
de masques on va recommencer avec les
injures merci en tout cas à tous les
deux pierre-jean un terme à nyon ludovic
toro d'avoir été avec nous après cette
prise de parole de jérôme salomon merci
les possibilités policière en matière de
fichage s'étoffe grâce à trois décrets
du ministère de l'intérieur publié
vendredi dernier repéré par nos
confrères de nexstim pacte il concerne
un des fichiers utilisés par la police
nationale et la gendarmerie à des fins
de maintien de l'ordre public activités
sur les réseaux sociaux des personnes
surveillées pratique sportive données de
santé comportements religieux
le gouvernement augmente ainsi
considérablement ses capacités de
fichage des individus et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec william
julier avocat spécialiste en droit pénal
et droit de l'homme
will i am j'ai eu lieu
et bonsoir merci d'être avec une
première réaction à cette augmentation
des capacités policière de fichage
écoutez c'est dans l'air du temps je
crois que c'est une réponse du politique
aux difficultés que nous avons connues
notamment l'année passée et cette année
en cours avec les problèmes de troubles
à l'ordre public et les difficultés
liées aux manifestations notamment des
gilet jaune
il n'y a pas que ça mais c'est
évidemment un des points importants qui
a motivé ces décrets alors vous l'avez
dit un accroissement des possibilités de
fichage parce que premièrement ces
fichiers vont être consultables par les
services de police les services de
gendarmerie et puis pour le troisième
par les services administratifs dans le
kate dans le cadre pardon des enquêtes
dites administratives qui peuvent être
conduites par un certain nombre
d'administrations donc une possibilité
pour un grand nombre de services
policiers gendarmes et administratifs de
d'avoir accès à ses fichiers là et ça on
le verra peut-être tout à l'heure mais
c'est une évolution importante parce qu'
un certain nombre de données était déjà
fiché par l'état dans le cadre d'autres
fichiers notamment fameux fichier des
renseignements généraux qui est gérée
par un décret anciens de 1991
donc là la nouveauté sait déjà qu'un
grand nombre de services vont pouvoir
avoir accès à des fichiers qui
d'habitude lorsqu'il comportait des
mentions dites sensibles étaient
réservées à des services plus
spécifiques et notamment à des services
de renseignement la deuxième chose qui
caractérise cet accroissement vous
l'avez rappelé c'est le fait qu'on va
pouvoir faire rentrer dans ce fichier
un certain nombre de données qui ne
figurait pas avant qu'il ne pouvait pas
figurer dans dans l'ancêtre de ces
fichiers là
à savoir qu'on va pouvoir maintenant
faire figurer des données sensibles
concernant la santé dans certaines
circonstances concernant les opinions
politiques concernant les orientations
idéologiques religieuses et même
concernant l'orientation sexuelle donc
ça ce sont des choses qui pourront être
conseillés
ces informations sont vraiment
nécessaires pour le maintien de l'ordre
public la santé les opinions politiques
religieuses est là j'y venais il y à une
nécessité tout de même que ces données
là soit articulé à une situation de
menace pour l'ordre public alors ce
n'est plus le terme que l'on retrouve
dans ces décrets là parce que on a
évolué de l'ordre public vers les
notions de sécurité publique
il faut que les personnes sur lesquelles
le fichier va porter représente un
danger puisse porter atteinte à la
sécurité publique à la sûreté de l'état
c'est le deuxième terme
ou alors et c'est un des termes qui fait
le plus débat puisse se porter atteinte
aux institutions de la république ou à
l'intégrité du territoire et donc il ya
là une conception assez large dans
laquelle non on ne sait pas très bien ce
qu'on va pouvoir trouver exactement de
menaces de danger pour l'ordre public et
pour la sécurité publique et il faudra
pour que ces données dites sensibles
soient consignées et bien qu'elle soit
en relation avec des gens qui présentent
ce type de menace ensuite il faudra
regarder au cas par cas et lapine il
pourra tout de même exercer des
contrôles a posteriori sur le fait que
ce qui va être consignées présente une
utilité en relation avec les risques que
je viens d'évoquer
mes gars la sécurité publique justement
la cnil a fait plusieurs mises en garde
d'un déjà ce que vous
partager ces réserves est ce qu'il ya un
risque sur la liberté individuelle des
personnes leur vie privée alors
absolument dans l'avis de la cnil
il y à une première chose qui frappe et
qui frappe un peu dans deux sens
d'ailleurs la cnil relève qu' il ya
certaines choses qui doivent peut-être
être revue ou surveiller notamment
concernant les interconnexions de ce
fichier avec d'autres notamment
concernant la façon avec laquelle les
informations vont être récoltés mais
indique aussi que il est d'une certaine
façon peut-être positif que des
pratiques qui existaient avant soit
régularisée et ça c'est tout de même
assez inquiétant ça donne l'idée que la
récolte
parce que c'est quand même le bon terme
de toutes ces informations sensibles et
bien été déjà pratiqué avant je les
mentionnaient tout à l'heure dans ce
fichier notamment des rg mais peut-être
dans d'autres types de fichiers le monde
du renseignement et le monde du droit
vis-à-vis des fichiers est un monde qui
parfois est assez obscures il y à un
certain nombre de fichiers sur lesquels
on sait rien ou quasiment rien parce que
les bases légales qui déterminent ce que
ce sont ces fichiers est ce qu'on peut
en faire
les décrets en l'occurrence ne sont pas
publiés donc la cnil a émis un certain
nombre en effet d'avis qu'ils ne
contraigne pas d'ailleurs le
gouvernement qui ont valeur consultative
et on verra ensuite s'il y a des
contrôles qui sont effectués puis on
verra aussi parce que sans doute il va y
avoir des actions de contestation de la
régularité de ces décrets devant les
juridictions administratives in fine et
peut-être devant le conseil d'état
voire même devant des juridictions
internationales ensuite cour européenne
des droits de l'homme cge cour de
justice de l'union européenne et on
verra dans un premier temps sans doute
ce que dit le conseil d'état on peut
rappeler que le conseil d'état en mai a
annulé un décret qui permettait à la
préfecture de police notamment de filmer
avec des drones la fois le public et le
conseil d'état a annulé le décret qui
permettait cela on verra ce que les
juridictions 10 décembre
les avocats spécialistes du droit pénal
et des droits de l'homme merci à vous
dans quelques instants rester avec nous
nous parlerons de la visite du président
égyptien à emmanuel macron le chef de
l'état qui remercie à 6,6 de son soutien
à la campagne de haine anti française
dans le monde musulman
et puis dans bien non sur la conclusion
d'une enquête menée par une ong les
constructions routières en cisjordanie
au profit des colonies israéliennes
n'ont jamais été aussi nombreuses
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent là l on soit vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche extrême tous les
témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
[Musique]
un des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense ont tout au long des aides
l'alliance atlantique s'est investi dans
des guerres qui n'étaient pas toujours
réellement en ligne avec ses objectifs
statutaires
la situation s'est aggravée avec le
début d' attaques contre la frégate
courbet qui juillet les mots nations
contre la grèce et la présence de thua
d'ist syriens venus dit libre haut
karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne
c'est à l'europe d'être en capacité
d'assumer la responsabilité de sa propre
sécurité et d'agir de manière autonome
quand c'est nécessaire mais compte tenu
des divergences avec quelle europe
pourront nous le faire
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle et 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée que la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'attitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non voilà comme
disait malraux
seuls les slams dit toujours oui ça leur
est inscrit au dessus du bureau de
chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent
des hommes d'état
[Musique]
20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez le président
égyptien al sisi est donc arrivé hier à
paris une visite d'état de deux jours
s'est entretenu ce matin avec la
ministre française désarmé avant d'être
reçu à l'elysée par emmanuel macron
lutte contre le terrorisme libye conflit
israélo-palestinien défis stratégiques
liés à l'iran ou encore crise politique
au liban les deux hommes sont sur la
même ligne mais c'est sur la question
des droits humains qu'ils étaient très
attendus emmanuel macron assuré avoir
évoqué le sort de plusieurs militants
des droits de l'homme emprisonnés
je ne conditionnent rep à notre
coopération en matière de défense comme
en matière économique à ces désaccords
d'abord parce que je crois à la
souveraineté des peuples et au respect
de nos intérêts légitimes c'est
réciproque
ensuite parce que je pense qu'il est
plus efficace d'avoir une politique de
dialogue exigeant qu'une politique de
boycott qui viendraient réduire
l'efficacité dans nos partenaires dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme et pour la
stabilité régionale
donc je vous réponds très franchement je
pense que faire un tel conditionnement
ne ferait pas avancer une seule seconde
les sujets que nous portons parce qu'il
romprait la discussion sur ces derniers
et conditionnerait plutôt à fragiliser à
nos partenaires dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme pour la stabilité dans la
région
donc ce serait inefficace sur le sujet
des droits de l'homme et contreproductif
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme c'est
pour ça que je ne le ferai pas un jeu
d'équilibriste pour emmanuel macron avec
cette visite officielle présentée comme
devant raviver les relations bilatérales
malmené justement ou par cette question
des droits de l'homme pierre qui savent
hivernaux
la dernière rencontre officielle entre
emmanuel macron et abdel fattah al-sisi
remonte à janvier 2019
le président français avait alors fait
le déplacement en egypte
la france et l'egypte sont des
partenaires de longue date mais leurs
relations sont au point mort depuis près
de deux ans celle ci pourrait connaître
un nouveau souffle à l'occasion de cette
visite
paris et le caire partagent la même
vision sur le conflit libyen la
situation méditerranée orientale et la
lutte contre le terrorisme depuis le
début du mandat dalle 6,6 en 2014 l'état
égyptien est devenu un client important
de la france dans le domaine de
l'armement notamment faisant
l'acquisition de 24 avions de combat
rafale lors de leur dernière rencontre
les deux chefs d'état ont signé de
nombreux contrats en rapport avec les
énergies renouvelables la santé
l'agroalimentaire et les transports
seule ombre au tableau le respect des
droits de l'homme lors de sa visite en
2019 emmanuel macron avait évoqué ce
thème devant son homologue égyptien une
sortie qui a quelque peu refroidi les
relations entre les deux pays
plusieurs ong parlent de la pire crise
des droits humains depuis plusieurs
années elle dénonce notamment des
condamnations à mort usage de la torture
et regrette le tapis rouge déroulé par
le président macron au chef de l'état
égyptien
juste avant sa venue à paris le
président al sisi a fait libérer trois
employés d'une ong de défense des droits
de l'homme et pour en parler nous sommes
avec claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir claude
blanche maison merci d'être avec nous
alors pourquoi la relation entre elles
la france et l'egypte est elle aussi
importante c'est pas nouveau c'est une
vieille affaire sans remonter au xviiie
siècle à l'expédition d'egypte de
bonaparte qui avait emmené comme vous le
savez 160 savant français dont celui qui
allait découvrir plus tard la façon de
décrypter les hiéroglyphes dans le fond
si les égyptiens savent lire aujourd'hui
les hiéroglyphes de l'egypte ancienne
c'est grâce à un savant français
plus récemment l'egypte avait décidé de
de rentrer dans de devenir membres de la
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie alors qu'il ya peu de
francophones aujourd'hui en egypte
c'était un choix politique est
d'ailleurs boutros ghali ancien
secrétaire général de l'onu est devenu
le secrétaire général de l'organisation
internationale de la francophonie
alors là que les choses se sont un peu
accéléré en effet depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir de monsieur de du président ici
puisque depuis 2014
on peut estimer que chaque année où tous
les 18 mois au maximum
il ya une visite d'état dans un sens ou
dans l'autre monsieur sisi est venu en
visite d'état en france
dès son élection en 2014 monsieur
hollande est allé l'année suivante en
egypte il a aussi assisté au doublement
de la capacité du canal de suez
et puis en 2017 eh bien il ya eu une
nouvelle visite de monsieur sisi en
france 2019
monsieur mâcon a fait du sud et à la
visite d'aujourd'hui c'est la visite
retour c'est dans la pratique
diplomatique normale
alors évidemment il ya beaucoup de
points de convergence en matière
politique
le premier et le plus important c'est
certainement la lutte contre le
terrorisme puisque les analyses
française et égyptienne sont totalement
convergente
c'est aussi la sphère de la libye où là
la france comme l'egypte considère qu'
il faut absolument appliquer le cessez
le feu
il faut mener à bien le dialogue
politique il faut éviter les
interventions extérieures
et puis la crise en méditerranée
orientale
évidemment là c'est encore la turquie
qui est visé puisque les deux pays
considère qu' il ne faut pas qu'ils
interventions intempestives qui viennent
bousculer les zones économiques
exclusives et les possibilités de
recherche d'hydrocarbures dans la région
donc cela fait beaucoup de points
communs plus les accords de coopération
beaucoup d'entreprises françaises sont
installées en egypte et par conséquent
il ya beaucoup de sujets de coopération
dans divers domaines et je crois que
demain le président si six rencontres
le président du sénat qui la rencontre
est ce soir le président de l'assemblée
nationale et la maire de paris
ça fait partie du protocole d'une visite
d'état la mère du paris lui a sans doute
également beaucoup parlé
en effet les droits de l'homme alors
cette visite justement du président
égyptien est vraiment critiquée en
france
oui elle est critiquée par un certain
nombre de partis politiques par les ong
par un certain nombre de militants des
droits de l'homme parce que en effet il
semble qu'il y ait envie plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de prisonniers
politiques en egypte et les deux
présidents sont d'ailleurs expliqué
devant les journalistes dans leur point
de presse commun et le président 6,6
répond oui mais naturellement notre
région est particulièrement dangereuse
et moi je veux lutter contre tous les
terroristes islamistes y compris
d'ailleurs contre les frères musulmans
or en egypte il a remplacé monsieur
morsi qui appartenait à la confrérie des
frères musulmans et les frères musulmans
sont souvent soupçonné d'une certaine
complaisance il à vis de terroristes
islamistes
évidemment cela n'est pas une raison
pour mettre en prison des journalistes
des avocats des gens qui appartiennent à
la société civile et on a en effet cette
situation qui fait que les ong et bien
disent pourquoi vantant le de l'armement
désarmement des équipements militaires à
un pays qui n'appliquent pas les droits
de l'homme alors justement l'armement
occar un de ses relations entre les deux
pays quelles perspectives pour la france
pour ce marché concurrentiel de
l'armement alors en 2014 eux c'étaient
les etats-unis qui étaient le premier
fournisseur de l'egypte et puis les
difficultés au congrès donc le
ralentissement des fournitures
américaine et finalement aujourd'hui
c'est la france qui est le premier
fournisseur d'armements à l'egypte la
russie et le second et les etats unis
sont le troisième mais il ya évidemment
d'autres pays qui vendent aussi des
armements la grande bretagne l'allemagne
et beaucoup d'autres pays parce que
c'est un pays qui en effet vivant dans
une région particulièrement dangereuse
a besoin de s'équiper surtout que
naturellement l'egypte n'a jamais
cherché à bénéficier de l'armé nucléaire
et qui lie à d'autres pays dans la
région qui l'on pourrait bien l'avoir
donc y est évidemment pour l'egypte
c'est un enjeu tout à fait essentiel si
d'un marché très compétitif et je crois
qu'à l'avenir le président 6,6 aura le
seul le souhait de conserver cette
diversification des approvisionnements
naturellement et surtout qu'il cherchera
à apprécier la fiabilité des différents
fournisseurs et évidemment également les
risques de sanctions
merci à claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales et en
cisjordanie à présent les constructions
routières représente le plus important
développement d'infrastructures au
profit des colonies israéliennes depuis
les années 90 c'est la conclusion d'une
enquête publiée ce lundi par lorenzi
breaking the silence on prend le silence
en français si israël était engagé a
depuis cinq ans dans la planification
une accélération des travaux publics est
observé et j'avais une telle vitesse
dont les territoires palestiniens
conquis et occupé en 1967 depuis les
chantiers ouverts dans la foulée des
accords de paix d'oslo
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
michèle rameau ancien ambassadeur de
france en direct avec nous par téléphone
bonsoir à michel raimbault la
construction d'infrastructures routières
pourquoi une telle accélération et
pourquoi maintenant on va écouter je
pense que c'est lié aux notamment
nécessité de boucler tous les toutes les
promesses de donald trump avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard que vous comme souvent
mais je pense que c'est dû aux
incertitudes sur les résultats des
élections et aux etats unis les prix
petite lan koné est donc finalement
cebrian ça rajoute beaucoup
d'incertitudes à l'avenir il ya les
promesses et bob non pas que les
israéliens puisse douter des bonnes
intentions de jubail donne si c'est lui
qui prend le pouvoir si celui qui rentre
à la maison blanche
mais en tout cas il faut mieux tenir que
de courir et dont il ya les promesses de
tromper je pense qu'ils veulent forcer
les feux ce qu'il ya plein de promesses
qu'il serait peut-être vu un petit peu à
la baisse
quand même donald s'est beaucoup de
promesses et de cadeaux disons en faveur
d'israël sur des choses qui ne lui
appartenait pas comme le goal ans comme
l'est la cisjordanie après structure sur
les coller les implantations et c'est la
capitale éternelle d'israël à jérusalem
le transfert de l'ambassade américaine
je pense qu'il s'agit de capitaliser
tout tous ces acquis et donc bon pour
les colonies 10 en cisjordanie et ils
ont dans les territoires palestiniens je
crois que s'il s'agit de créer nour est
accomplie et donc il faut des
infrastructures routières puisque
l'expérience trouve que temps finalement
dans cisjordanie et en palestine façon
générale dans les territoires occupés
tout ce qui a été fait c'est toujours
créé des faits des faits des faits
accomplis qui sont irréversibles ensuite
donc ça s'ajoute cette inclus dans ces
inclus dans territoire israélien et peu
comme quand il est là mais c'est terminé
la messe est dite
je pense que si et centre il faut le
préciser michel raimbault qui ne
considère plus les colonies israéliennes
comme contraire au droit international
ça dure finalement il ya plus de droit
international du tout donc finalement
n'y a plus rien qui soit contraire ni
conforme au droit et un gardien qui est
conforme au droit international
mais comme il ya plus de droit
international il est bien de faciliter
ces deux idées de dire ce qui est
contraire au droit international du film
existe plus haut que tout le monde fait
enfin dix ans les états unis et israël
font comme si ce droit interne ça
n'existait plus sinon il n'y aurait pas
eu toutes ses promesses
on sait forcerait du temps de mettre en
oeuvre les résolutions des nations unies
et du conseil de sécurité qui prévoit
quand même une solution à deux états
dans la solution à deux états on en est
bien loin
il ya une solution à un seul état mais
les dieux a garanti depuis 1948 quand on
est loin de la solution de l'état
palestinien
je vois pas très bien sur quelle base
territoriale il peut se fonder sinon sur
une prison à ciel ouvert qu'est la bande
de gaza mais sur la cisjordanie et
jérusalem je crois que c'est fortement
compromis
alors ça veut pas dire que ça fait
accompli les fait accompli une sont
accomplies vraiment que lorsque c'est
accepté par les parties mais la banque
s'est pas être habillée par les
palestiniens mais je pense qu'en plus on
israël veut que je veux sur fait si on
peut dire sur la grande vague d'amour
qu'il porte au moyen orient d'ampleur la
vague normalisation des états arabes
notamment avec le qatar avec l'arabie
saoudite avec le part dans le bac à
laignes avec les émirats arabes unis
et puis avec le soudan par exemple dans
la région et puis on peut éventuellement
derrière va pas tarder à venir sans
doute arabie saoudite
il ya toute une vague de normalisation
et pour pour disons mettre en oeuvre ce
que ce qui avait été appelée la
transaction du siècle qui est
parfaitement accepté par la partie
israélienne n'est malheureusement pas du
tout par faire alors pas du tout ça va
de soi par la partie il y parle vie
palestinienne romanisation michel
raimbault qu'elle va en être la
conséquence on les conséquences ça va
rendre impossible à rendre avant de la
rendre encore plus impossible je dirai
ce qu'il l'était déjà
c'est à dire une solution à deux états
puis la reprise y compris de pourparlers
les palestiniens veulent plus rien
entendre je trouve qu'ils ont été très
très patient demain probablement trop
patient disons d'attentes de ne vouloir
négocier à tout prix quelque chose qui
manifestement du côté d'israël n'est pas
négociable
je pense que ça n'a jamais été
l'intention d'israël finalement vu avec
du recul il n'a jamais été dans
l'intention d'israël finalement leur une
solution à deux états seulement de
gagner du temps et de profiter des
aubaines comme celle qui a été le mandat
de donald trump comme sont en fait les
aubaines de tous les présidents
américains et ce serait le cas de joe
biden pas pour l'avenir
disons d'abord des décisions favorables
ce rallye sainte qui sont défendues
défendu à 100% sans réserve que le droit
international n'existe plus et que bien
rare rarissime sur les états qui
expriment leurs positions y compris bug
parmi les pays arabes ils sont pas les
seuls j'irai dans la communauté
internationale ou ce qui en tient lieu
avec des guillemets je pense qu'on ne
voit plus très bien un seul et à
s'opposer à son caprice d'israël et
dorsaux posées à ce que décident les
états unis et de l'otan comme ce sera
michel raimbault l'euro le rôle de
l'europe sa marge de manoeuvre au le
rôle de l'europe écoutait s'il y avait
un rôle de l'europe indépendant de celui
des etats-unis et d'israël on ne saurait
on leur ait vue là je crois que
finalement c'est une seule peine perdue
même les étapes qui jadis donc dans
l'histoire l'histoire récente ou un
semis récentes comme la france avait
milité quand même à rabat ses vêtements
pour la cause palestinienne et pour la
solution danila 2 état d'une solution à
deux états et arabes est un état juif je
pense que
finalement séduit c'est du passé ça ne
depuis d'un certain dernier déjà la
france a rejoint les rangs de la
longueur atlantique et de du sionisme et
de l'atlantisme il ya plus ya plus de
aucune marge de manoeuvre
les palestiniens je pense pas sur quoi
ils peuvent compter donc ils peuvent
compter sur une certaine unité mais ils
ont mis très très longtemps là réalisé
entre les mouvements islamistes qui vont
pouvoir à gaza et puis l'autorité
palestinienne qui a tous les autres
mouvements d'emploi reçues jordanie ils
ont ils ont mis beaucoup de mal à s'unir
et encore une fois il ya beaucoup de
rivalité ses tresses une unité très très
fragile
et puis je crois qu'il est un petit peu
tard pour parler de gaïapresse que
plusieurs biens en cisjordanie haillan
et à jérusalem en tout cas il n'y a plus
de ya pratiquement plus de base
territoriale il ya des postillons comme
on dit deux de ses plus hauts depuis un
archipel avec des petits lots de
palestiniens ccd vraiment des postillons
et des restes des traces et bientôt il
suffira lait coûte cher pierre et y en a
plus du tout alors il y aura encore des
palestiniens bien évidemment dans un
politiquement la base de l'état
palestinien malheureusement elle se fait
de plus en plus étroite et déjà risque
d'être re concentrés sur gaza qui elle
même un métier me met mal y est assiégée
et qui n'a pas de aucune des
attributions et aucune des possibilités
d'un état indépendant puisqu'il est
encerclée par israël sur la mer est
réparée sur la terre soit pas on voit
pas très bien comment ça peut devenir un
état indépendant
quant à la cisjordanie je sais pas je ne
vois pas comment ça peut marcher
faudrait vraiment une révolution des
tulipes le matic et une l1 un retour une
révolution dire un retour du droit
international dans toute sa splendeur et
encore pour remettre sur le h sur la
route road est sur ses pieds une
solution politique à deux états
notamment
alors ne parlons plus des résolutions
des nations unies en elle 80 90 ou plus
ou 100 150 entre des résolutions du
conseil de sécurité des recommandations
de l'assemblée générale pourtant israël
est un état qui est une évolution des
nations unies et pour ne pas péter quoi
merci beaucoup ancien ambassadeur
france merci à vous dans le reste de
l'actualité dans le reste de la [ __ ] de
l'actualité au liberia 2 millions et
demi d'électeurs sont appelés aux urnes
ce mardi pour un référendum
les libériens doivent dire s'ils
approuvent oui ou non une modification
de la constitution
ce vote est couplée avec les élections
sénatoriales de mi-mandat un scrutin qui
a valeur de test pour le président de
george weah et la medjahed des
supporters déchaînés dans la capitale
libérienne des scènes de joie lors d'un
meeting de l'ex footballeur vedette
george williams le président tente de
mobiliser une dernière fois avant le
référendum constitutionnel partisans
distinguer
mesdames et messieurs je veux que vous
disiez oui au référendum parce que c'est
dans votre intérêt
deux millions et demi de libériens
appelés à se prononcer sur huit
amendements à la constitution de 1986
les électeurs doivent notamment dire
s'ils sont pour ou contre la réduction
de 6 à 5 ans de la durée du mandat
présidentiel
une révision constitutionnelle qui
propose aussi de réduire d'une année la
durée des mandats des députés et de deux
ans ceux des sénateurs un référendum qui
dérange dans les rangs de l'opposition
je vais voter trois oui les cinq autres
seront des noms vous savez en ce qui
concerne le référendum
je n'ai pas encore compris donc pour le
référendum je n'y ferais pas vraiment
vu en fait j'estime que le référendum
n'est pas opportun et je pense qu'il
n'aurait pas dû avoir lieu à ce moment
là car il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de
publicité autour du référendum
les contestataires craignent que georgia
tire profit du changement de
constitution une alliance composée des
quatre principaux partis d'opposition
estiment que peu des lecteurs
comprennent la portée des changements
proposés et appellent au boycott
il briguera un troisième mandat
simplement parce que ses six premières
années se serait déroulée sous une autre
constitution voté oui au référendum
serait une erreur pour l'opposition le
président libérien pourrait un jour
vouloir imiter certains de ses pairs
ouest africain en allant au delà de la
limite de deux mandats présidentiels
autre question qui continue à diviser la
société du liberia la double nationalité
interdite depuis 1973
le projet de nouvelle constitution
prévoit que tout enfant né d'au moins un
parent libériens serait automatiquement
un citoyen naturelles du pays et qu'il
aurait le droit de détenir une autre
nationalité
une chose est sûre le référendum prend
la forme d'un test pour jean juilla qui
voit sa popularité largement érodé
notamment auprès des jeunes qu'il avait
pourtant porté au pouvoir il ya près de
trois ans l'élection de l'homme de 54
ans ballon d'or france football 1995 a
soulevé un immense espoir au liberia
mais depuis que jean juilla est
président la situation économique s'est
encore aggravée dans ce pays d'afrique
de l'ouest notamment avec la crise du
coronavirus un jour de vote aujourd'hui
au ghana plus de 17 millions d'électeurs
avaient jusqu'à 18 heures pour élire
leur président ainsi que leurs deux sont
75 députés et parmi elles les 12
candidats dont trois femmes deux hommes
sont les principaux favoris
le chef d'état sortant dana akufo addo
et son rival de toujours l'ancien
président john mahama c'est la troisième
fois consécutive qu'il se retrouve face
à face et les résultats devraient être
serrés
versèrent politique historique et se
sont toutefois engagés à respecter les
résultats et à garantir la paix et la
sécurité
je me sens optimiste et je me sens bien
je suis heureux que le processus se
déroule bien dans tout le pays qu'ils se
déroulent dans la paix voilà qui
renforce l'engagement du peuple ghanéen
envers les institutions et le processus
démocratique et je m'attends à ce que le
travail que le gouvernement a accompli
ces quatre dernières années
trouve aujourd'hui la faveur du peuple
ghanéen est notre mandat sera renouvelée
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur le point presse du
directeur général de la santé jérôme
salomon prévient nous sommes encore loin
de l'objectif des 5000 cas par jour puis
nous parlerons des négociations parce
breakes site les conditions ne sont pas
réunies pour un accord entre londres et
l'europe selon un communiqué commun ce
soir il soupçonne est attendu à
bruxelles dans les prochains jours
[Musique]
un des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense auront tout au long des années
l'alliance atlantique s'est investi dans
des guerres qui n'étaient pas toujours
réellement en ligne avec ses objectifs
annuels la situation s'est aggravée avec
le début des attaques contre la frégate
courbet 10 juillet les mots nations
contre la grèce et la présence de thua
d'ist syriens venus d'idlib haut
karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne
c'est à l'europe d'être en capacité
d'assumer la responsabilité de sa propre
sécurité et d'agir de manière autonome
quand c'est nécessaire
mais compte tenu des divergences avec
quelle europe pourront nous le faire
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir en ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
des côtes maintenant c'est l'industrie
qui gagne mais du coup peut-être qu
est-ce qui va rester c'est que les films
qui seront de plus en plus fait pour le
cinéma et pas sur les grands réseaux
resteront des objets artistiques godard
qui disait cette chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma on lève
les yeux
tout est dit
[Musique]
où
est ce que la ville dos et mortifère ce
n'est pas la danse hip et brûle c'est à
dire le rapport entre la population et
territoire qui est porteur de causalité
une explication mais des densités un
train si l'on dit un appartement il ya
des chaînes de contagion dit se font à
l'intérieur vraisemblablement du milieu
familial parce que on a des familles qui
vivent à trois générations et c'est tout
cet ensemble de causes qui
constitutionnellement un syndrome en
quelque sorte social et dont le
gaullisme est à la fois le révélateur
est malheureusement la cause des pères
didams fonctionne je suis très frappé
entre représentants des sciences
sociales par finalement le progrès
considérables qu'on a fait dans cette
pandémie qu'avant dérivation n'a pas que
des mauvais côtés en un an on a mis au
poids pratiquement
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'attends
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous parlerons de tout sans langue de
bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment on peut expliquer que le groupe
est énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire rasé à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle créait un
incident c'est pour l'éternité
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
détail sonic a recruté dans toutes les
couches de la société sans faire de tri
des mineurs des femmes des délinquants
des criminels de droit commun tout le
monde est venu à jaca en syrie il ya
encore quelques quelques années au
moment de charlie hebdo flou du bataclan
il y avait un état islamiste qui
semblait diriger tout ça la bascule et
se fait justement en 2015 et smith est
un peu le passage de relais d'al qaïda
l'état islamique quelque part dans notre
politique internationale vis bien
évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de kia et
de cet appel d'air justement où en
recrutement l'a malheureusement fait en
séries mais en irak
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres
et entre la liberté individuelle et la
liberté collective il faut choisir
la gouvernance est compliqué la pandémie
après les gilets jaunes le terrorisme
islamique ça fait quand même beaucoup
tout ça
le fondement de la politique c'est la
rumeur ont réagi à des rumeurs plus qu'à
des réalités ça comme conséquence que la
politique est devenue un métier les
spectacles la loi est un objet de
communication politique
trop de lois tuent la loi d' et les lois
inutiles thulé vol nwa
[Musique]
d
où
bonsoir à tous 21h heure française soit
il est bienvenu en direct sur rt france
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 7 décembre
nous sommes encore loin de l'objectif
des 5000 cas par jour jérôme salomon
alerte la saison hivernale sera très
difficile
le directeur général de la santé s'est
exprimé tout à l'heure insistant sur le
risque élevé de rebond épidémique alors
que les fêtes de noël approchent des
propos pessimistes avant une nouvelle
prise de parole de jean castex jeudi
avec des annonces à attendre le royaume
uni sur le pied de guerre la campagne de
vaccination démarre demain le premier
pays dans le monde à avoir autorisé le
déploiement du vaccin développé par un
faiseur et bio ntech les négociations
post break si tout reste à faire selon
londres il ya toutes les chances pour
qu'elle échoue et des conditions pas
réunies selon un communiqué commun avec
l'europe dans l'essonne est attendu à
bruxelles dans les prochains jours le
royaume uni qui exclue des négociations
l'année prochaine en cas d'échec cette
année l union européenne ne reconnais
pas les résultats des élections
législatives organisées au venezuela car
elle ne juge pas crédible processus
électoral annonces du chef de la
diplomatie européenne
washington de son côté continue de
considérer juan gouaille dos comme
président alors que la russie elle a
fait l'éloge d'élections transparentes
réactions après la victoire du parti de
nicholas maduro qui reprend le contrôle
du parlement avec un scrutin marqué par
une très forte abstention
[Musique]
le haut karabagh au coeur des
discussions ce matin entre le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères et son
homologue arménien sergueï lavrov se
félicite du respect de l'accord de paix
entrée en vigueur le 10 novembre dans
cette région contestée mais également du
travail des forces de la paix russes
[Musique]
débute avec la crise du coronavirus en
france et les derniers chiffres pas
vraiment optimiste santé publique france
dénombre 3411 cas de kobe détecté en 24
heures 366 personnes sont décédées à
l'hôpital en recul par rapport à lundi
dernier le taux de positivité des tests
s'établit désormais à 10,7 pour cent et
le directeur général de la santé jérôme
salomon a donc tenu un point presse tout
à l'heure sur l'évolution de la crise
sanitaire alors que se profile un
éventuel déconfinement le 15 décembre
prochain
les précisions de notre reporter n'est
des chefs des arts à sac le
déconfinement 15 décembre n'aura
peut-être pas lieu comme annoncé par
emmanuel macron le 24 novembre dernier
ce jour là le chef de l'état avait
annoncé qu'il fallait atteindre
l'objectif des cinq mille nouveaux cas
de contamination par jour au minimum
pour diminuer et les restrictions
sanitaires et on en est aujourd'hui au
double à une semaine de l'échéance le
directeur général de l' agence de santé
publique s'est montré inquiet
aujourd'hui lors de sa conférence de
presse il a prévenu qu'il faudra
attendre les prochains jours pour
prendre d'éventuelles mesures
supplémentaires afin de lutter contre la
propagation du virus jérôme salomon a
aussi déclaré que si le taux de
contamination était aussi élevé il n'est
pas dû au comportement des français un
éventuel relâchement de leur part mais
aux conditions météorologiques au froid
à l'hiver tout simplement une saison qui
est propice à la prolifération des virus
interrogé sur les fêtes de fin d'année
il a appelé les français au bon sens si
les a encouragés à continuer à respecter
les gestes barrière la situation
actuelle n est pas très encourageantes
en france mais en croire jérôme salomon
elle est moins pire qu'ailleurs en
europe
un conseil de défense doit avoir lieu ce
mercredi on sait déjà que jean castex
prendra la parole le lendemain pour
annoncer d'éventuelles nouvelles est
difficile et un possible report du
déconfinement et la russie elle a entamé
ce week-end sa campagne de
six nations contre le kobe 19 son accent
spoutnik v a été distribué à travers 70
clinique un sujet signé youla chapeau 20
à l'eau va avec hélène masquelier nous
nous trouvons dans les locaux de la
société bio cad à saint pétersbourg
c'est l'un des laboratoires qui a signé
un contrat avec le gouvernement pour
produire le premier vaccin anti qu'ovide
enregistrés en russie
le spoutnik vu sa production à grande
échelle a déjà commencé venez voir ce
pique nique v est un vaccin à deux doses
utilisant des adénovirus comme vecteur
vous en avez peut-être déjà entendu
parler à la différence de certains
autres vaccins anti copie 19
internationaux les vecteurs de spoutnik
v ont recours à des adénovirus d'origine
humaine et non animale mais qu'est ce
qu'un vecteur au juste il s'agit d'un
virus modifiés dépourvu de gênes de
reproduction et donc un capable
d'infecter ce qu'il fait c'est servir de
véhicule pour les protéines du coc vide
pendant trois semaines un patient va
recevoir deux piqûres différentes pour
développer des anticorps et ainsi une
résistance à la maladie
le vaccin utilise de 12,7 un processus
assez complexe en terme de production
parce qu'il faut produire deux vaccins
et non pas un seul dans la pièce
derrière moi le vaccin est mis en
bouteille
ici il est emballé cette ligne
particulière est capable de produire
6000 bouteilles par heure soit trente
mille doses chaque bouteille contient
cinq doses destinées à autant de
personnes à vacciner avant de se faire
vacciner chaque patient est examinée
pour s'assurer qu'il est en bonne santé
il faut ensuite quinze minutes pour
décongeler le vaccin le spoutnik v est
stocké à -18 degrés celsius et les
développeurs affirment que c'est un
avantage par rapport au vaccin conçu par
d'autres pays qui exigent eux des
températures de stockage nettement
inférieur après injection les médecins
vous gardent sous surveillance pendant
30 minutes avant de vous laisser
repartir
je travaille dans l'éducation et je suis
en contact direct avec les enfants
j'enseigne la chorégraphie par
conséquent je ne peux pas garder mes
distances avec les enfants comme c'est
le cas pour d'autres enseignants
il ya une communication tactile avec les
enfants pour corriger tel ou tel
mouvement
je pense que la vaccination est un
excellent moyen de me protéger et
surtout de protéger mes proches ou bien
encore mes parents qui ont plus de 65
ans contre ce virus
j'ai donc profité de cette opportunité
dès qu'elle s'est présentée j'ai été
examiné par un médecin il m'a demandé si
j'avais des maladies chroniques des
douleurs il a mesuré ma pression
artérielle consulter mon dossier médical
électronique
puisqu'il n'y avait aucune
contre-indication j'ai été autorisé à me
soumettre à la procédure
tout s'est déroulé très rapidement j'ai
d'abord reçu un message qui indiquait
que je pouvais être vaccinés je suis
vraiment heureux d'avoir une telle
opportunité parce que cela me donne la
possibilité de me protéger contre toutes
nouvelles infections en coronavirus
j'avais des doutes mais j'ai pris une
décision et me voilà ici aujourd'hui
le vaccin est distribué aux quatre coins
du pays
en même temps les militaires eux aussi
reçoivent le spoutnik v en russie la
vaccination contre le coc vide 19 et
volontaire et gratuite
et bien que certaines personnes soient
encore sceptique sur la sécurité et
l'efficacité du vaccin
la plupart s'accordent à dire que seule
la vaccination à grande échelle
permettra de mettre fin à la pandémie
tu es la campagne de vaccination débute
demain au royaume uni le pays a été le
premier à valider le recours au vaccin
mis au point par les laboratoires pfizer
et biotech
le royaume-uni est le pays d'europe le
plus touché par le commis 19 priorité
aux personnes les plus vulnérables et
aux plus de 80 ans mais aussi au
personnel des maisons de retraite et des
services publics de santé et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct depuis aix
et terre au royaume uni avec bharat en
khâgne à expert en maladies
transmissibles et infectieuses à
l'université d'exeter c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir baraquements kenya merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france le
premier au monde donc à homologuer un
vaccin contre la pandémie source de
fierté pour vous au royaume uni c'est un
grand jour demain quel est votre état
d'esprit ce soir je pense que c'est une
source de fierté pour toute l'humanité
ce n'est pas le royaume uni et en
premier qui est important le monde doit
être fier que en moins d'un an nous
ayons réussi à produire un vaccin
efficace qui va servir toute l'humanité
c'est une bonne chose
alors vous l'avez vu en france il ya
beaucoup de scepticisme y compris même
chez les scientifiques ont longtemps sur
des plateaux de télé nous dire voilà on
n'a pas le recul nécessaire
on a eu pour l'instant que des bribes
des communiqués mais pas vraiment
d'études scientifiques vous n'êtes pas
vous dans cet état d'esprit en tant que
scientifique au royaume uni j'ai étudié
les éléments donnés par les organes de
réglementation au royaume-uni notamment
l' agence du médicament britannique qui
a expliqué comment elle a analysé les
données et d'ailleurs cela fait
longtemps que cette agence est utile les
données elle a obtenu les données à
partir d'octobre et l'analyse
depuis cette époque et a continué à
l'analyse et jusqu'au d'un séjour de la
production donc cette agence la mhr a
est un organisme indépendant qui n'est
pas soumis aux pressions politiques et
qui ne va pas faire des économies rogner
des parties du processus ce sera en tout
cas une grande erreur de le faire donc
si on vous comprend bien vous êtes assez
confiant
vers 7 agences de santé britannique qui
a étudié selon rouler les études donc si
antifi car les les données scientifiques
mais pour vous c'est ailleurs il n'ya
pas de frein freins administratifs par
exemple c'est bien de ça qu'il s'agit
effectivement je lui fais confiance et
je ne n'ai pas de questions sans réponse
la question sans réponse par exemple
aurait pu être est ce que cela
représente un danger est ce qu'il y a
des séquelles des effets secondaires
dangereux
toutes ces questions ont eu des réponses
de la part de pfizer bayer tech je n'ai
pas eu un accès direct aux données
je ne travaille pas au sein de cet
organe comme ça de ce régulateur
mais j'ai pu avoir accès à leurs
déclarations j'ai vu leur travail depuis
octobre et pour moi c'est suffisant cet
organisme a pris une décision en à temps
record mais cela ne signifie pas qu'il y
a eu du bâclage pourtant c'est une
méthodes modernes la rn qu'on n'a pas
encore expérimenté ça ne vous inquiète
pas plus que cela oui effectivement
c'est une technique moderne et c'est une
très bonne chose de savoir qu'un tel
vaccin fonctionne c'est une très bonne
nouvelle
nous essayons de développer des vaccins
à la rn message est depuis longtemps et
enfin la technologie fonctionne cette
technologie nous permet de construire
une membrane de nanoparticules afin de
protéger un brin darel pour qu'ils
puissent arriver aux cellules et faire
son travail
la différence avec le vaccin de pfizer
bayonne tech et par exemple le vaccin
spoutnik fife où les vaccins
d'astrazeneca
c'est l'utilisation d'une méthode
différente afin de transmettre les rênes
de la porter à la cellule sinon le
résultat est très similaire alors la
reine et son époux pourrait se faire
vont se faire vacciner certainement ça
vous inquiète et donné l'âge de la reine
vous vous dites que c'est une bonne
chose
c'est une très bonne chose car les
personnes âgées qui seraient contaminés
par l'aco vite pourrait avoir une
maladie plus grave et seraient plus
susceptibles de mourir donc la priorité
numéro 1 bien sûr ce sont les personnes
de plus de 80 ans les personnes âgées et
ensuite les personnes qui ont des
comorbidités et on arrive ensuite aux
autres groupes le vaccin est difficile à
déployer je pense qu'on va utiliser ce
vaccin temps on a que celui là et
lorsque le vaccin dette
zeneca et de l'université d'oxford sera
disponible ou les autres alors nous
allons déployer ses autres vaccins afin
de vacciner bien plus rapidement car
leur utilisation est beaucoup plus
simple que ce vaccin riser band take on
parlait de la reine qui va se faire
vacciner c'est un symbole fort qui
pousserait également les populations qui
pourraient être sceptique à se faire
vacciner elle aussi je l'espère mais le
plus important à mon sens c'est que les
politiques ne doit pas s'ingérer
les experts de la santé des experts
indépendants doivent être en mesure de
transmettre des messages clairs honnête
et sincère quant à la façon dont le
vaccin fonctionne comment ils protègent
quels sont les effets secondaires afin
de rassurer le public d'expliquer que
tous les tests ont été mises en oeuvre
et que le vaccin est sûr c'est une
stratégie au royaume unis comme en
europe comme d'autres régions du monde
pendant kenya comment ça va se passer
demain vous ne faites pas partie des
prioritaires vous êtes encore trop jeune
mais comment ça va se passer pour les
personnes plus âgées elles vont se
déplacer chez leur médecin ou dans les
hôpitaux de main parce qu'on sait que
c'est très difficile à stocker 1 ce
vaccin puisqu'il a besoin de deux gels
de grand froid comment ça va se passer
concrètement ce sera ma dernière
question au royaume uni nous avons 50
ressentent hospitalier où le vaccin est
stocké dans des super réfrigérateur le
plus simple serait de vacciner les
personnes sur place les personnes les
plus vulnérables les plus âgés et
ensuite elles pourront rentrer à la
maison ou dans leur maison de retraite
ce serait la façon la plus simple
d'opérer dans le même temps on pourra
également en profiter pour vacciner les
professionnels de la santé qui
travaillent dans ces hôpitaux ou autour
de ces hôpitaux donc étape par étape
nous commençons
rémy knees et les personnes au sein de
la communauté hospitalière et ensuite
nous allons trouver des façons sur de
transférer ces vaccins dans les cabinets
médicaux afin d'immuniser les personnes
plus largement de manière très sûr même
si c'est long merci un bar à teint pâle
kenya expert en maladies transmissibles
et infectieuses à l'université d'exeter
merci à vous les conditions ne sont pas
réunies pour finaliser un accord post
break site londres et bruxelles viennent
tout juste de communiquer à ce sujet le
premier ministre britannique boris
johnson et la présidente de la
commission européenne ursula von der
leyen se sont entretenus au téléphone
hier soir et aujourd'hui
avant ce coup de fil très attendu une
visioconférence a eu lieu entre le
président français la chancelière
allemande le président du conseil
européen et la présidente de la
commission européenne dans l'essonne est
attendu à bruxelles dans les prochains
jours mais pour land je cite il y a
toutes les chances pour que les
négociations post break si tu échoues si
cet échec se confirme le royaume uni
exclut déjà des discussions l'an
prochain et les négociations post
brzeski tu patines donc toujours les
blocages persistent notamment on en a
beaucoup parlé de l'accès à la zone de
pêche britannique alors les anglais ont
ils intérêt à un audit quelle
conséquence va avoir l'absence d'accord
pour les pêcheurs français peuvent-ils
accepter cette situation c'est l'objet
de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
pour en parler nous sommes avec bruno
margolle président de la fédération des
organisations de producteurs de la pêche
bonsoir bruno margollé merci d'être avec
nous jeremy hills tous à vos côtés
représentants du parti conservateur
britannique bonsoir à vous aussi jeremy
tous merci d'être là on l'a compris en
ce soir clairement il pourrait y avoir
un odile en tout cas les négociations
sur le break si tu patines copieusement
toujours aucun accord encadrant les
relations au poste pour exciter ça
semble mal partie ce sont les anglais
qui font échouer les négociations sur
les méthodes ce haut il faut deux
parties pour échouer
est ce qu'on dit c'est ce que dit tout
le monde sait que les deux parties sont
également assez loin l'un de l'autre et
donc ce qu'il faudrait c'est que chacun
fasse suffisamment de concessions mais
pour le moment les enjeux sont trop
grands et parmi ces enjeux il faut aussi
remarquer que c'est la durée potentielle
des engagements qui font peur des deux
côtés c'est à dire chaque parti craint
de prendre des engagements dans la durée
y qui vont se révéler assez rapidement
très peu propices à son évolution
économique et donc nous attendons
toujours des pas en avant de chaque côté
tout le monde semble pessimiste en ce
moment il reste si je viens compris un
peu plus de 48 heures
peut-être qu'il y aura comme souvent
dans le passé un grand coup de théâtre
ou dernier moment oui et bruno margolle
vous quel est votre sentiment ce soir
quand vous entendez ces dernières
nouvelles qu'un accord pourrait être
compliqué
pour vous en aux deals ça aurait quelles
conséquences sur les pêcheurs français
justement il faut dire que on est à 22
jours de la fin des commandes la période
de transition donc c'est quand même les
états d'esprit son centre est le châssis
saugeen que c'est très compliqué pour
pour les pêcheurs en tout en tout cas
pour les pêcheurs ddo de france à tous
les tous les pêcheurs qui sont inféodés
à la manche 1
on n'imagine pas à aucun instant être
comment être rejetée de 2,1 historique
de pêche depuis des décennies ces jeux
je n'imagine pas un seul instant
donc ça serait vraiment catastrophique
pour les pêcheurs français en tout cas
de ne pas pouvoir accéder à nos zones de
pêche historique depuis des décennies je
n'imagine pas je vous dis franchement
moi je suis embarqué en 1974
depuis 1974 on évolue dans la manche
moi je suis une mer du nord que côté
français côté anglais je n'imagine pas
un conte moment de ne plus pouvoir
accéder à ces zones de pêche
pourquoi j'ai rien demandé alors
justement on va essayer de mieux
comprendre ses excès aux zones de pêche
parce que ça peut paraître un peu
abstrait comme ça de l'extérieur c'est
l'un des points clés précisément de
cette négociation
regardez pour bien savoir à quoi ça
correspond fait un petit schéma regarder
ce petit schéma ça c'est la situation
donc actuelle les hollandais les
allemands les belges les français et les
anglais pêche tous donc dans la manche
pas de problème donc pour vous les
pêcheurs français demain avec un audit
particulièrement voilà à quoi va
ressembler cette zone on voit clairement
le problème insuline pour séparer les
eaux anglaises des européennes résultats
la concentration des pêcheurs allemands
belges et hollandais le long des côtes
françaises et plus du tout évidemment
répartis dans la manche
on comprend mieux la colère des pêcheurs
français non
mrs les problèmes s'étendent des deux
côtés parce que si il y à un une absence
d'accord
les pêcheurs britanniques vont se
retrouver avec plein de poissons qu'ils
auront du mal à vendre parce qu'il y
aura désormais des des taxes
d'importation sur le continent donc
encore une fois les deux parties ont
tous les deux intérêt à faire un pas en
avant et à se rencontrer au milieu en
fait les discussions assez complexe
parce que non seulement on parle de
territoriale et de poissons mais on
essaie aussi de diviser les types de
poissons la profonde des mères etc
on se demande si s'il sera possible d'en
venir à bout dans les 48 heures qui
reste un mois que à moins que la pêche
la pêche ne reste un enjeu uniquement
parce que on n'a pas encore réglé
les autres questions c'est à dire les
questions des règles sur la concurrence
en général
et puis les mécanismes de règlement de
conflits si la pêche est juste à un
élément que contient en otage peut-être
qu'il y aura une solution à mon avis je
persiste à croire que l'absence d'accord
le no deal
même si tout le monde est pessimiste ce
serait de la folie et qu'on n'ira pas
jusque là
bruno margolle vous dites quoi aux
anglais vous ce soir il faut absolument
trouver un accord c'est ce sera de la
concurrence déloyale jusqu'au bout j'y
croire madame jusqu'au bout
gd confiance à nos négociateurs je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec
avec comment stéphane je sais plus ce
que c'est moi j'ai perdu seront jérémy
pardon mais je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec lui qu'il faut à tout prix trouver
un deal n'est pas à n'importe quel prix
tout simplement je pense que des deux
côtés il ya des deux côtés de la manche
il ya d'un côté ils ont accès au marché
d'un autre côté nous on a accès aux
zones de pêche et je pense que c'est
très important dans les deux côtés ça
serait catastrophique pour eux aussi
bien pour le royaume uni que pour pour
comment le l'union européenne ça serait
catastrophique d'arrivée un new deal et
ben voilà on a peine à panser ses
blessures ou de problèmes de
cohabitation
ça fait 15 ans 20 ans que que les
pêcheurs de chaque côté de la manche
font des efforts de pour la sélectivité
pour améliorer les stocks de poisson et
j'ai bien peur que l'absence de
négociations pas de doute il ferait que
dans quelques mois voir on mettrait tout
à plat dans l'espace de quelques mois
j'ai simplement en tout cas au bord du
gouffre un londres et bruxelles pour
l'instant sont pas vraiment sur votre
toit ligne à ils ont exclu toute reprise
des négociations après le 31 donc
beaucoup de pression c'est ce qu'a
déclaré le porte parole du premier
ministre écoutent et nous sommes prêts à
négocier tant qu'il reste du temps
disponible
si nous pensons qu'un accord reste
possible mais je peux exclure une
reprise des négociations l'année
prochaine jim rmistes au besoin on
comprend que vous avez quand même un
petit peu pitié nos pêcheurs français
mais quand même un new deal vous
arrangerait en tout cas sur ce problème
précis de la pêche quand on voit ce
schéma ce graphique on a vu tout à
l'heure ça crève un petit peu les yeux
quand même un odile n'arrange personne
sur quoi que ce soit s'il s'agissait
uniquement d'un accord a négocié entre
la france et le royaume uni sur la pêche
je pense qu'on aurait déjà trouvé la
solution il ya longtemps
en même temps quand on entend ces
déclarations que ce soit
des britanniques ou de la part de
bruxelles
ce sont des déclarations de fin de
négociation et donc on peut s'attendre à
ce que chacun dise il n'y aura pas de
concession où on n'ira pas au delà du 31
et cetera et cetera on verra bien on
verra bien parce qu'encore une fois ce
serait vraiment idiot de ne pas trouver
une solution même temporaire même en
attendant quelque chose de beaucoup plus
développé du complet comme accor on
verra bien le suspens en tout cas reste
entier puisque jamais merci à tous les
noeuds bruno margollé d'abord été avec
nous pour débattre notamment de l'accès
aux zones de pêche alors que les
négociations patinent sur le front du
bric site merci à tous les deux donc
quelques instants rester avec nous nous
parlerons du venezuela l'union
européenne ne reconnais pas les
résultats des élections législatives
organisées car elle ne juge pas crédible
le processus électoral réactions après
la victoire du parti de nicholas maduro
qui reprend le contrôle du parlement
et puis nous parlerons du haut karabagh
au coeur à des discussions ce matin
entre le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères et son homologue arménien
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut être défenseurs du
climat de la nature et des animaux et en
même temps aimait la chasse bien sûr
c'est avoir conscience justement des
populations de comment les gérer
si aujourd'hui on arrive à plus ou moins
trouver un équilibre entre la
l'urbanisation l'agriculture et puis les
espaces naturels c'est grâce à la chasse
grâce aux chasseurs
selon des ong la chasse est la cause de
disparition de certaines espèces j'ai
bien l'impression que les espèces sont
sont en grande partie conservée grâce à
la gestion des chasseurs aujourd'hui
vous avez vingt trois ans vous êtes une
femme qu'est ce que vous espérez
apporter justement à ce monde de la
chasse si je peux aider avec avec ce que
je fais sur les réseaux sociaux expire à
montrer un autre aspect de la chasse et
à donner envie à certaines personnes de
la découvrir
en
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative ressort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des soul unis vers une forme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas
l'oublié parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez au venezuela le
parti du président nicholas maduro on
reprend le contrôle du parlement
elles selon les premiers résultats le
parti socialiste et ses alliés ont gagné
les élections législatives avec 67% des
voix selon les premiers résultats des
élections boycottées par l'opposition
est marqué par une forte abstention est
les explications de françois tissier
beach ambiance festive dans ce théâtre
de caracas des dirigeants du parti
socialiste le parti de nicolas sma
dureau célèbrent leur victoire lors des
élections législatives
une victoire importante pour le
président bolivarien lui permettant de
reprendre le contrôle de l'assemblée
nationale perdue il ya cinq ans
[Musique]
nous avons eu la patience la sagesse
d'attendre cette heure d'attendre se
joue pour nous débarrasser de cette
infâme assemblée nationale qui a blessé
les vénézuéliens qui a apporté le fléau
des sanctions de la cruauté de la
douleur de la souffrance nous avons été
patients nous résistons et aujourd'hui
avec le vote
nous rendons justice nous rendons
justice avec ce vote un scrutin sans
véritable suspense car boudé par
l'opposition wang wei dos n'a d'ailleurs
pas attendu les résultats pour annoncer
qu'ils avaient été écrits à l'avance le
chef de l'opposition appelle les
vénézuéliens à manifester ce samedi et à
participer à une consultation populaire
pour prouver que la population rejette
ces législatives
bien que je ne puisse pas promettre une
solution magique aujourd'hui je peux
vous dire avec certitude et sécurité
vous n'êtes pas seuls nous n'allons pas
abandonner
nous allons tout donner jusqu'à ce que
nous gagnons et malgré le fait qu'ils
peuvent prendre une fois de plus par la
force le siège du parlement en tant que
président par intérim je continuerai ici
avec vous en assumant non seulement le
principe de continuité constitutionnel
la responsabilité du parlement tout en
défendant notre mission protéger le
peuple vénézuélien des élections
marquées par un très faible taux de
participation
31% seulement contre 71 lors des
dernières législatives
une abstention qui s'explique en partie
par les appels au boycott mais aussi
sans doute par une réelle lassitude des
vénézuéliens face à une crise politique
qui s'éternise et pour en parler avec
nous meriem laribi journaliste pour le
site web de rt france spécialiste de
l'amérique latine bonsoir
quelles sont les conséquences de cette
élection au niveau intérieur
bonsoir ses fans et oui le gouvernement
donc récupérer une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale il y aura donc une
certaine cohérence institutionnelle à
nouveau avec un parlement qui ne sera
plus dans une posture de défiance
ouverte envers le pouvoir exécutif
concernant l'opposition qui a présenté
donc des candidats plus de 13 mille
candidats une partie de l'opposition à
présenter des candidats et elle a
remporté 18 % des suffrages
donc un certain nombre de députés de
l'opposition pourront siéger à cette
assemblée nationale et exercer leur rôle
de double de coupables de contre pouvoir
au parlement
ces élections permettent donc de sortir
d'une situation de blocage total au
venezuela qui avait cours depuis 2015
date des dernières élections
législatives remportées majoritairement
par l'opposition incarnée par croire
wang bo depuis depuis deux ans
principalement qui était dans une
dans un refus total de tout dialogue
avec le pouvoir exécutif et qui avait
comme leitmotiv comme seul leitmotiv de
renverser le gouvernement et la personne
du président élu nicolas maduro
le leader de l'opposition à roanne guido
appelé au boycott de ces élections est
ce que les résultats ne me donnent
raison
il est indéniable que la que l'absence
que l'abstention pardon et a été très
importante elle est à hauteur de 69 %
alors l'appel de roanne gouardo qui est
le leader d'une partie de l'opposition
il faut le préciser a certainement
fonctionner mais ce n'est peut-être pas
le seul paramètre à prendre en compte
pour analyser cette forte abstention
il y a d'une part la crise sanitaire qui
touche tous les pays et qui n'épargne
pas le venezuela qui a pu jouer dans
cette forte abstention
on a pu le voir d'ailleurs dans des
élections en roumanie des élections
législatives en roumanie hier avec le
même taux d'abstention on a pu le voir
en france en juin avec une forte
abstention lors des municipales au
deuxième tour des municipales il y avait
une me semble 59 % d'abstention au
deuxième tour des municipales en france
donc la crise sanitaire peut expliquer
cette forte abstention et au venezuela
elles s'additionnent à une crise
économique extrêmement forte qui touche
la population de manière très brutale la
population on est réduite aujourd'hui à
ce
à chercher au quotidien des solutions
pour le pour lutter pour sa survie pour
l'alimentation pour par exemple les
files sont interminables pour trouver de
l'essence pour se ravitailler en essence
et donc il faut penser aux régions les
plus reculées du venezuela qui ont
peut-être besoin d'une voiture pour se
rendre dans les bureaux de vote et qui
faute d'essence n'ont pas pu il y a
évidemment toutes ces crises ont pu
engendrer une crise de confiance qui est
fait que les gens sont un peu lassé
comme vous l'avez dit dans votre sujet
et qui donc qui est peut-être une crise
de confiance politique
en tout cas la crise économique est la
conséquence est vraiment une conséquence
des sanctions économiques brutal à me
poser au venezuela par les états unis et
leurs alliés on en reparlera mais
le quotidien des venezuela et des
vénézuéliens et en tout cas marqué par
ce quotidien extrêmement dure et qui est
la principale de leurs préoccupations
avant même de peu de vous pensez à
participer au jeu électoral alors au
niveau international à quoi faut-il
s'attendre alors sans surprise les états
unis et leurs alliés ont
n'ont pas reconnu l'élection il l'avait
annoncé avant même la tenue du scrutin
mike pompéo a qualifié les élections de
mascarade électorale l'union européenne
a dit qu'elle ne reconnaîtrait pas les
résultats de toute façon il l'avait
annoncé en avance l'union européenne
avait refusé de
d'envoyer des observateurs malgré
l'invitation du gouvernement vénézuélien
il faut rappeler que
donc oui les états unis continueront à
soutenir wrong way dont ils ont annoncé
en tout cas l'administration tram
continuera à le faire on ne sait pas
maintenant si c'est elle qui gardera le
pouvoir aux états unis wang wei de il
faut le rappeler quand même aurait pu
participer librement à ces élections
mais il a refusé d'y participer et il a
appelé au maintien et à l'amplification
des sanctions économiques contre son
propre pays de la part des états unis
et c'est ce qui c'est on semble prendre
cette route là en tout cas du côté des
puissances occidentales ces sanctions il
faut il faut il faut le dire comme comme
j'essayais de le dire tout à l'heure on
a un impact humain important le cep est
requis et le centre d'études en
recherche politique et économique qui
est basée à washington a fait une étude
sur l'impact des sanctions et il a
établi que elle était à la source de
dizaines de milliers de morts en fait
ils ont le cvr a publié une étude
estimant à 40 mille le nombre de
bénévoles et les acquis sont morts des
conséquences des sanctions économiques
qui frappe leur pays
voilà du côté de la rue si évidemment ce
n'est pas du tout le même son de cloche
la russie avait envoyé
des observateurs pour contrôler le bon
déroulé du scrutin le ministère des
affaires étrangères a publié un
communiqué un peu plus tôt dans la
soirée et a regretté que les autres pays
européen
et occidentaux n'est pas envoyé
d'observateurs j'aimerais vous lire ici
une partie du communiqué le processus
des élections au venezuela a été
organisée de manière plus transparente
et responsable à bien des égards que
dans certains états qui se sont habitués
à se considérer comme des étalons de la
démocratie difficile de ne pas voir ici
une petite pique à l'adresse des états
unis qui viennent de vivre des élections
présidentielles avec c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire un certain cafouillage
merci meriem laribi journaliste pour le
site web de rt france et spécialiste de
l'amérique latine le haut karabagh à
présent au coeur des discussions ce
matin entre le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères et son homologue
arménien une nouvelle réunion organisée
par moscou après la signature d'un
accord de paix entrée en vigueur le 10
novembre dans cette région contestée du
haut vers le bar les deux hommes ont
tenu une conférence de presse dans la
foulée de cette rencontre et
correspondances à moscou d'antoine
claireaux le ministre arménien des
affaires étrangères fraîchement nommé
s'est rendu à moscou pour son premier
déplacement à l'étranger l'occasion de
souligner que les accords du 9 novembre
signé entre la russie l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan ne sont qu'une première
étape et qu'il est désormais nécessaire
de définir un statut à cette région du
haut-karabakh erevan est d'ailleurs
disposés en discuter directement avec
bakou dès que la situation sur place
sera réellement stabilisée et le rôle de
la turquie clarifier l la turquie en
tant que principal instigateur et
inspirateur de l'agression de
l'azerbaïdjan contre le peuple du haut
karabagh continue à mettre en place une
politique pernicieuse pour la région
cela oblige la communauté internationale
employer tous les moyens possibles afin
de contraindre la turquie à s'abstenir
de toute action pouvant aggraver
davantage les tensions et si ce souhait
voir journée personnes
la turquie doit retirer ses forces
armées et les groupes terroristes
affiliés de la zone du conflit du haut
karabagh et du sud caucase en général
pour le moment il n'y a pas eu de
message clair sur le retrait des
terroristes étrangers de la région
sergueï lavrov s'est à son tour félicité
du respect du cessez le feu sur le
terrain depuis maintenant quasiment un
mois mais aussi du travail des forces
russes
de la paix présentes sur place d'après
le ministre russe l'objectif pour tous
doit maintenant être un retour à la vie
normale pour la population sur place
sans considérations ethniques ou
religieuses sergueï lavrov également
commenté une déclaration du chef de la
diplomatie européenne josé barrel qui
s'est inquiété du rôle de la russie mais
aussi de la turquie dans ce dossier ces
autochtones et moi si je comprends bien
monsieur morel et d'une certaine manière
préoccupé par le fait que quelqu'un
d'autre part à l'union européenne puisse
prendre l'initiative dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui
je vous rappelle que si elle par exemple
concernant les balcons
le prédécesseur de monsieur morel madame
mot guérini a déclaré il ya un certain
temps quand l'union européenne se
présentent dans les balkans ou dans
d'autres régions
les autres n'ont rien à y faire comm vco
ensuite quand perplexe nous avons posé
des questions ils ont commencé à faire
semblant d'avoir été mal interprétés
mais en réalité tout le monde avait
parfaitement compris ni l'europe pour le
dossier du haut-karabakh donc encore
loin d'être clos mais au moins
maintenant c'est la diplomatie qui a
pris le dessus sergueï lavrov va
maintenant bientôt se rendre en arménie
sur une invitation qu'il vient
d'accepter une invitation de la part de
son homologue arménien il pour en parler
nous sommes avec un françois costantini
et géopolitologue bonsoir françois
santini merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france pour évoquer ce dossier
est ce qu on peut désormais parler d'une
situation apaisée mais finalement loin
d'être réglée au quart hama alors il est
vrai il est vrai que les armes se sont
tues mais sur le terrain la situation
est train d'être satisfaisante puisque
si l'arménie a récupéré son corridor en
effet par lequel il y avait la jonction
avec le haut karabakh est par contre des
territoires qui ont été amputés haut
karabakh est en effet on a fait état de
17 ans de malversations de comportement
est mise en danger du patrimoine pense
que ce qu'il faut déplorer c'est bien
sûr que cette question n'ait pas été
réglée avant donc coupe d'un cadre du
groupe de contact de mise contre la
russie les etats-unis et la france avec
l'azerbaïdjan l'arménie de la turquie
et quand on roule s'accorde pas en effet
qu'il soit elles sont durables
c'est-à-dire que si lazare agence
recouvre en effet ces territoires perdus
en 1992 94
parce qu'ils étaient dans une logique il
ne faut pas non plus amputé le haut
karabakh comme c'est fait aujourd'hui et
contre l'intégrité territoriale
retrouver de l'azerbaïdjan il faut en
effet reconnaître le caractère arméniens
du haut-karabakh est également le faire
venir à ses frontières internes tels que
c'est avant mais il faut avouer que l'on
gère en conséquence ici un programme pro
un programme qui est quelque peu
insoluble certains eiffel sete
ce mécano de diabolique avait été mis en
place ou non ce éthiques notamment avec
staline cet enchevêtrement des peuples
et tout ça ne peut être gérée que par
négociation et le moins possible bien
sûr pas peut-être par par un conflit
pour vous ce n'est donc pas une affaire
terminée
c'est un conflit qui peut ré exploser à
tout moment
aujourd'hui concrètement parce que en
effet on a vu l'azerbaïdjan avait pris
le dessus il ya une mutation stratégique
depuis 25 ans qui est très importante
c'est que là vous savez il ya deux
hommes essentiel se ranger aux
politiques c'est le les tendances
démographiques et la puissance de feu et
il faut le constater l'arménie a perdu
sur ces deux plans à la décrocher au
plan démographique puisque aujourd'hui
pour un arménien il ya 3 il ya 3 3 à 0
et sur le plan de l'armement en effet
l'azerbaïdjan a développé une politique
de puissance tous azimuts ayant déjà
fourni par la russie par israël en
conséquence et puis on sait bien sur
l'apport aujourd'hui la puissance qu'on
pas que la puissance tutélaire turc
puisque les azéris ont sont perçues
comme un prolongement de de l'historique
de la delà de la nation turque pimpante
hop entourent agnel et là on peut penser
que la situation est figée pour deux ans
mon sens pau un certain nombre de temps
au profit de l'azerbaïdjan en ces terres
qu'elle s'était figé pour 25 ans au
final le dollar manille mais aujourd'hui
le le contexte géopolitique c'est
totalement retourné alors justement la
communauté internationale comme la
france à vaudrey que le rôle de la
turquie soit précisée ça vous semble
être une priorité à vous aussi si le
rôle de la turquie doit être précisée il
faut que la turquie soit une table de
négociation avec les autres et qu'elle
joue un rôle d'une puissance qui
négocient ces terres que en effet la
solution c'est que que les abattages ans
est retrouvé sur l'intégrité
territoriale et est un fait mais que le
nagorny karabakh voit en effet son
caractère arménien a affirmé puissance
est une population un territoire qui a
toujours était arménien et aujourd'hui
même le haut karabakh est amputé d'un
certain nombre de ces partis donc il
faut revenir sur le conte peut appeler
en quelque sorte de droit international
même si sage cette frontière interne
avec l'intégrité las de l'azerbaïdjan
mais aussi l'intérêt du du haut karabakh
et qui devrait être à mon sens une
solution équilibrée sur le terrain avec
une gare ans
mieux sur le terrain aujourd'hui
effectués par la turquie et la réussite
je ne vois pas d'autres pays en train de
de s'impliquer puisque le lait la france
a été a été absente depuis le depuis le
début et les états unis en plan en
pleine campagne l'éditorial carole alors
que avec la france les etats-unis la
russie
il copréside le groupe de contact demi
sur le haut-karabagh mis en place depuis
un quart de siècle
ils n'ont pas du tout été en mesure
d'agir en tout cas effectivement les
rues sont seuls sur place désormais il
assure la force au niveau de la paix
mais aussi l'équipement de missions
humanitaires notamment est un avion
cargo d'ailleurs qui amenait des
équipements il ya deux jours c'est une
mission compliquée oui c'est une c'est
une mission compliquée puisque il y ait
non seulement l'humanitaire mais
également un afflux très important de
réfugiés vers vers l'arménie proprement
dites 1a sa tante de population d'une
haut-karabakh voyant leur leur
territoire des hommes est sous tutelle
azerbaïdjan au passage en plus on ne
sait pas quel sera le sort juridique du
haut-karabakh puisque c'était un un
territoire je rappelle autonome armenia
autonome au sein de l'azerbaïdjan est
alors que ce territoire qui a terminé un
doit avoir également son statut
définitif a précisé pour la sécurité de
sa population est ce qu'on va parisien
dépendre attachement l'armée lee
d'autonomie ça il va falloir très vite
tracer les contours juridiques du
haut-karabakh respecte également les
frontières tels cas telle qu'elle avait
fait et là c'est difficile parce que
c'est le fait militaire qui a parlé au
delà du fait juridique et géographique
en effet la fda du mali terré et est
aujourd'hui qui est compliqué parce que
il y à des réfugiés et que aujourd'hui
en effet la russie essaye de maintenir
ces populations arméniennes sur place
mais celle ci en effet saisi d'un
certain effroi honte ans à affluer
massivement vers alain maignan c'est
qu'erevan aujourd'hui accueille
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
réfugiés du haut karabakh
merci à vous françois constantini
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france dans le reste de l'actualité est
interrompue depuis près d'un an le
chantier du gazoduc nord stream ii qui
reliera la russie à l'allemagne est sur
le point de reprendre
mais les états unis sont toujours
réticents au projet ils réclament un
moratoire sur la construction du
'pipeline' le point avec grégoire douce
et c'est dans les tuyaux
si rien n'est encore officiel plusieurs
signaux semblent montrer une reprise
très prochaine du chantier nord stream 2
interrompu depuis de longs mois
l'office allemand des voies navigables
et de la navigation de stralsund en
bordure de la mer baltique a notamment
communiquer sur des travaux de pose de
pipelines est allé sur le mois de
décembre
la reprise se précise donc ce qui
provoque des remous du côté de
washington
ouvertement réfractaires à un tel projet
le moment est venu pour l'allemagne et
l'union européenne d'imposer un
moratoire sur la construction du gazoduc
il ya près d'un an c'est justement suite
à des sanctions économiques imposées par
trump aux entreprises oeuvrant pour ce
chantier que celui ci a été suspendue
alors qu'il touchait presque à sa fin
la diplomatie russe de son côté regrette
cette nouvelle tentative américaine de
perturber la collaboration entre moscou
et berlin les gazoducs russes quelle que
soit leur destination peu importe
l'époque où ils sont installés
quelles que soient les traités qu'il est
légitime suscite depuis des décennies
toujours la même réaction de la part des
états unis
l'agression politique et l'opposition
illégales je voudrais dire à washington
vous ne pouvez pas jouer contre les
règles si vous voulez être un acteur
responsable dans l'économie
internationale
vous devez respecter les règles estimé à
plusieurs milliards d'euros le colossal
chantier de nord stream 2 prévoyait
initialement la conclusion des travaux
pour la fin de l'année 2019
il est censée s'inscrire en complément
du premier gazoduc north stream en
service depuis 2012 ce nouveau projet
pourrait permettre de transporter une
quantité de gaz nettement supérieure sur
une ligne directe entre la russie et
l'europe occidentale via la mer baltique
et tout comme un art ce crime de l le
précédent gazoduc avait lui aussi connu
deux
une période entre la conception du
projet et sa mise en service les détails
en images
[Musique]
m
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans
quelques instants pour un point complet
sur l'actualité de la journée
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir on ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
déco maintenant c'est l'industrie qui
gagne mais du coup peut-être qu est-ce
qui va rester c'est que les films qui
seront de plus en plus fait pour le
cinéma et pas sur les grands réseaux
resteront des objets artistiques godard
qui disait cette chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma enlève
les yeux de teddy
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qu'il a c'est fini pour moi est
ce que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que la ville dense et mortifère
ce n'est pas la densité brut
c'est-à-dire le rapport entre la
population et kate doit supporter de
causalité une explication mais des
densités un train si l'on dira
département il ya les chaînes de
contagion des autos à l'intérieur
probablement milieu familial parce qu on
a des familles qui vivent à trois
générations et c'est tout cet ensemble
de causes qui constitutionnellement un
syndrome en quelque sorte social et dont
le coït est à la fois le révélateur est
malheureux dans la cause déterminante
pompiers suis très frappé en rente
représentants des sciences sociales par
finalement le progrès considérables
qu'on a fait dans cette pandémie cas
mondialisation n'a pas que des mauvais
côtés en un an on a mis au poids
pratiquement aveugle
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins et
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
sap est une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs là arrivent à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pj jones étaient
des valeurs de droite
c'était les gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas de la louve
ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu'il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis
répond en appartement on est énervé
donner le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ce
qu'il est guéri moi je voudrais pas
qu'on les fasse un tour de tracteur avec
nos clients campagne il faut savoir
c'est qu'une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas forêts et aider un peu
plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ça soit réduire
le débat de rappeler que c'est un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est con ça que c'est
un sujet très très épidermique parce que
s'il est une histoire de vie et de mort
il faut protéger la végétation pour
protéger la faune il faut protéger notre
santé
tout ça c y et n'oublions pas que tous
nos problèmes viennent du mépris qu'on a
sur le reste du monde vivant donc il
faut il faut arrêter de laisser les
chasseurs faire leur bêtise je suis poli
[Musique]
nous sommes encore loin de l'objectif
des 5000 cas par jour en jérôme cèderont
alerte la saison hivernale sera très
difficile de directeur général de la
santé s'est exprimé tout à l'heure
insistant sur le risque élevé de rebond
épidémique alors que les fêtes de noël
approchent des propos pessimistes avant
une nouvelle prise de parole de jean
castex ce jeudi avec des annonces à
attendre emmanuel macron dit avoir
évoqué en toute franchise est question
des droits de l'homme avec son homologue
égyptien en visite d'état de deux jours
en france mais il ne conditionne pas la
coopération entre paris et le caire à
ces désaccords selon ses mots interrogé
sur la publication des caricatures de
mahomet en france le président égyptien
affirmé que les valeurs religieuses
devraient avoir la suprématie sur les
valeurs humaines la valeur de l'homme
est supérieur à tout lui répond emmanuel
macron
les négociations passe breakes site tout
reste à faire selon londres il ya toutes
les chances pour qu'elle échoue les
conditions pas réunies selon un
communiqué commun avec l'europe boris
johnson est attendu à bruxelles dans les
prochains jours
le royaume uni qui n'exclut pas des
négociations qui exclut pardon des
négociations l'année prochaine en cas
d'échec cette année
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez on débute
avec donc la crise du coronavirus en
france et les derniers chiffres santé
publique france dénombre 3400 ce cas de
kobe détecté en 24 heures 366 personnes
décédées à l'hôpital en recul par
rapport à lundi dernier le taux de
positivité des tests s'établit désormais
à 10,7 pour cent et le directeur général
de la santé jérôme c'est le mans a donc
tenu un point presse tout à l'heure sur
l'évolution de la crise sanitaire alors
que se profile un éventuel déconfinement
le 15 décembre prochain les précisions
de notre reporter nadège à dera sach le
déconfinement 15 décembre n'aura
peut-être pas lieu comme annoncé par
emmanuel macron le 24 novembre dernier
ce jour là le chef de l'état avait
annoncé qu'il fallait atteindre
l'objectif des cinq mille nouveaux cas
de contamination par jour au minimum
pour diminuer et les restrictions
sanitaires et on en est aujourd'hui au
double à une semaine de l'échéance le
directeur général de l' agence de santé
publique s'est montré inquiet
aujourd'hui lors de sa conférence de
presse il a prévenu qu'il faudra
attendre les prochains jours pour
prendre d'éventuelles mesures
supplémentaires afin de lutter contre la
propagation du virus jérôme salomon a
aussi déclaré que si le taux de
contamination était aussi élevé il n'est
pas dû au comportement des français un
éventuel relâchement de leur part mais
aux conditions météorologiques au froid
à l'hiver tout simplement une saison qui
est propice à la prolifération des virus
interrogé sur les fêtes de fin d'année
il a appelé les français au bon sens il
les a encouragés à continuer à respecter
les gestes barrière la situation
actuelle n est pas très encourageantes
en france mais à en croire jérôme
salomon elle est moins pire qu'ailleurs
en europe
un conseil de défense et doit avoir lieu
ce mercredi on sait déjà que jean castex
ça prendra la parole le lendemain pour
annoncer d'éventuelles nouvelles est
difficile et un possible report du
déconfinement écoutez écoutez à ce
propos pierre jean
interne a mis en radio log président de
la fédération des médecins libéraux
d'auvergne et rhône-alpes et ludovic
toro médecin porte parole du collectif
de soignant ses 19 on va dire c'est pas
forcément des mauvais chiffres
c'est une décélération le problème c'est
que depuis à peu près une semaine on est
en plateau et en étant plateau parce que
on a une sorte de plancher et sur lequel
on n'arrive pas à descendre et à peu
près dix mille trois cent on a toujours
des régions qui sont largement au dessus
on va dire 200 ça s'explique
probablement par la réouverture des
commerces le souci je réitère ses tanks
giving qui est un exemple l'exemple
américain où on est à peu près sûr que
on va dire à la mi-janvier dans la
troisième vague
si effectivement d'un relâchement on a
un relâchement depuis à peu près une
dizaine de jours avec ouverture des
commerces donc automatiquement les
chiffres montrent on est en plateau
on n'a aucune idée de l'évolution du
plateau et dans tous les cas on
n'atteindra pas les 5000 ça c'est sûr il
faut qu'on arrête de donner des chiffres
des prévisions et courir après des
choses qu'on tient pas parce que ça
c'est le message très négatif à l'ironie
pas de problème dormez tranquilles on
est tous mis en place on aura cinq mille
contaminés et aujourd'hui on dit que
c'est pas possible on n'arrête pas de
faire des annonces des contrats non si
les îles étant d'anticiper
on connaît ce virus aujourd'hui on est
on est à 15 % à peu près d' immunité
collective 15% on était à 8 % au 1er
confinement et on doit attendre 70 %
pourquoi ça s'arrêterait aujourd'hui
mais on sait très bien qu'en hiver on
est tous les uns chez les autres et rien
est ouvert c'est comme toutes les
épidémies
on n'est pas en été on le fait on n'a
pas découvert pour décembre ont fermé
les fenêtres et aurait fait dans les
maisons et la russie elle a entamé ce
week-end sa campagne de vaccination
contre le comique 19 son bac sans un
scout nick v a été distribué à travers
70 clinique un sujet signé youla
chapoval au bas avec hélène masquelier
nous nous trouvons dans les locaux de la
société bio cad à saint pétersbourg
c'est l'un des laboratoires qui a signé
un contrat avec le gouvernement pour
produire le premier vaccin anti qu'ovide
enregistrés en russie
le spoutnik vu sa production à grande
échelle a déjà commencé venez voir
spoutnik v est un vaccin à deux doses
utilisant
les adénovirus comme vecteur vous en
avez peut-être déjà entendu parler à la
différence de certains autres vaccins
anti copie 19 internationaux les
vecteurs de spoutnik v ont recours à des
adénovirus d'origine humaine et non
animale mais qu'est ce qu'un vecteur au
juste
il s'agit d'un virus modifiés dépourvu
de gênes de reproduction et donc un
capable d'infecter ce qu'il fait c'est
servir de véhicule pour les protéines du
coc vide pendant trois semaines un
patient va recevoir deux piqûres
différentes pour développer des
anticorps et ainsi une résistance à la
maladie
le vaccin utilise de 12,7 un processus
assez complexe en terme de production
parce qu'il faut produire deux vaccins
et non pas un seul dans la pièce
derrière moi le vaccin est mis en
bouteille
ici il est emballé cette ligne
particulière est capable de produire
6000 bouteilles par heure soit trente
mille doses chaque bouteille contient
cinq doses destinées à autant de
personnes à vacciner avant de se faire
vacciner chaque patient est examinée
pour s'assurer qu'il est en bonne santé
il faut ensuite quinze minutes pour
décongeler le vaccin le spoutnik v est
stocké à -18 degrés celsius et les
développeurs affirment que c'est un
avantage par rapport au vaccin conçu par
d'autres pays qui exigent eux des
températures de stockage nettement
inférieur après injection les médecins
vous gardent sous surveillance pendant
30 minutes avant de vous laisser
repartir
je travaille dans l'éducation et je suis
en contact direct avec les enfants
j'enseigne la chorégraphie par
conséquent je ne peux pas garder mes
distances avec les enfants comme c'est
le cas pour d'autres enseignants il est
à une communication tactile avec les
enfants pour corriger tel ou tel
mouvement
je pense que la vaccination est un
excellent moyen de me protéger et
surtout de protéger mes proches ou bien
encore mes parents qui ont plus de 65
ans contre ce virus
j'ai donc profité de cette opportunité
dès qu'elle s'est présentée
j'ai été examiné par un médecin il m'a
demandé si j'avais des maladies
chroniques des douleurs il a mesuré ma
pression artérielle consulter mon
dossier médical électronique
puisqu'il n'y avait aucune
contre-indication j'ai été autorisé à me
soumettre à la procédure